the supreme court plans to review
affirmative action policies in cases
against harvard and the university of
north carolina this consideration of
race and school admissions has long been
a polarizing topic and has come up
several times in recent decades
any shift when the justices hear the
cases later this year would set a new
legal precedent so i want to bring in
ucla school of law assistant professor
latoya baldwin clark now to get some
clarity professor thank you so much for
joining us welcome to quick take there's
obviously a lot to unpack here starting
with the fact that we have a supreme
court in which six of the nine justices
are conservatives what does it signal
that the court has agreed to hear these
cases involving harvard and unc
considering race in their admissions
process
yeah so you know
what the court is signaling i think is
that um after the last affirmative
action cases um the court was very clear
that using race as part of a holistic
idea of how students should be
gathered as a class for diversity sake
um that was just a few years ago that
was just in 2016.
and therefore the fact that they're
taking up this case again this type of
case again in such a short amount of
time i think really just signals the
changing
political persuasion of the court rather
than any new evidence that has come to
light about affirmative action
interesting you mentioned the 2016 case
i want to go back to 2003 because the
decision known as gruder versus
bollinger reaffirmed that universities
can take race into account so i wonder
um how does it lay the groundwork for
how the supreme court justices might
think about the upcoming cases that
they're considering
sure so the groundwork in that case said
that universities even public
universities are able to use race as a
factor and considering putting together
an entire class for the sake of
diversity and quite honestly um gretter
is a direct precedent for the case that
is coming up right now i mean so it's
going to be difficult i think for the
plaintiffs to actually make a case as to
why we should change now and that
precedent that has been sitting like you
said for you know over 10 years um it's
not clear to me exactly how the um how
the plaintiffs in this case are actually
going to
unprevail given uh the decision
ingredient okay well what i found
interesting in that greta case is that
the majority opinion from sandra day
o'connor uh was that racial preferences
would no longer be necessary in 25 years
25 years has come uh and gone
well it hasn't yet but um it's
interesting how she's framed things in a
certain way and that hasn't exactly come
to pass how do you think that will
influence their thinking
i mean that's a great question i think
that when justice o'connor put that in
her opinion many people were very
surprised as it wasn't necessary to
actually settle that case now of course
i think the plaintiffs are going to use
those words when they come before the
supreme court again and the supreme
court might ask themselves how different
is it now today than it was almost 25
years ago and my answer would be it's
actually not very different now at all i
don't think that we have a new set of
facts that would allow us to overturn
the precedent that was settled in greta
well a different group of people might
argue otherwise um when i applied to
college for instance being asian helped
me or at least didn't hurt me all things
being equal when my kids apply to
college they will be
an overrepresented minority as asians so
if you could talk a little bit about how
the relationship of race and education
educational access specific specifically
have evolved or have changed over the
last 18 years since grunder
yeah i mean i think that they've changed
in ways this this case is very
interesting because it does focus on
asian americans where generally when in
the past we've been thinking about
affirmative action from this very black
white um binary um but i think that what
has happened is that asian americans are
typically over represented
in these universities and that's not to
say that asian americans don't
necessarily deserve to be there it's
more of the factual point and that we
have an over-representation of
asian-americans
in schools and there's been some recent
data and some recent studies that says
even if we were to get rid of
affirmative action and only look at
things for example test scores the
actual percentage of asian americans
that would be admitted into these elite
universities would not actually change
all that much yeah there was a study
from georgetown that showed that the
percentage of asian americans would go
down by one percentage points and
actually the biggest beneficiaries would
be uh wealthy white men interestingly
enough in if they were to only look at
standardized test scores i know that
your specialty professor baldwin clark
is examining race and education at the
k-12 level and there's been a lot of
concerns or a lot of talk about
whether race should be a factor as well
in uh testing into selective high
schools i'm curious to hear what you
think are the common threads the
overlaps between race and education at
the k-12 level and race and education at
the university level are these good
comparisons to make
um i don't think that there are good
comparisons to make except for the fact
of when we're talking about elite
universities and elite schools uh k-12
schools i would actually think that we
need to look beyond just thinking about
the elite schools both at the high
school level and
at the university level because um black
children brown children and indigenous
children are suffering in their own
schools that are not necessarily elite
universities um the elite universities
or elite high schools um so i would
argue that we need to look broader than
that elite universities only make up a
very small amount of the colleges and
universities in our country and in those
colleges and universities affirmative
action is actually not a very big deal
what we should be trying to do
especially at the k-12 level is making
sure that all of our children have an
opportunity to be able to go to elite
university if they choose to and not
only through the elective the um elite
and selective high schools yeah legacy
and athletics actually probably play a
more prominent role than affirmative
action if anything one word that you
mentioned and that comes up a lot when
talking about college admissions is
holistic colleges defend their holistic
admissions process which is pretty much
a squishy term because it can mean
whatever the school wants it to mean in
whatever circumstance or context that
they happen to be in would abolishing
the consideration of race mean that
there is still room to consider other
factors like socio-economic background
or geography
that may intersect with race
yes absolutely and i think that's what a
lot of the um proponents of winning this
case would say is that not looking at
race well why don't we look at social
economics why don't we look at geography
why don't we look at all these other
things that actually may still bring the
diversity that we care about but through
these indirect uh mechanisms
yeah and i i also love what you said
about how this is a very specific issue
to elite high schools and elite colleges
and the world is a lot bigger than elite
schools
what is interesting to me as well in
these upcoming cases is the government's
stance because the trump
administration's department of justice
supported the lawsuits but justice under
the biden administration
supports the defendant here which is
harvard how big a role do you think the
doj will play
in the case can they affect the outcome
or maybe that's a wrong question to ask
can they affect the arguments that are
being put forth or how it's being
defended
oh sure so um they can submit amicus
briefs to the
justices that are what we call friends
of the court so these are briefs that
are written by people who actually feel
briefly written by people who have some
stake in the argument and want to bring
up particular arguments to the court
that perhaps the plaintiffs or the
defendants in this case have not brought
up so yes the court will absolutely look
at those amicus briefs especially the
one of course uh by uh doj okay and how
much sway will those amicus briefs
actually have though do you think in a
supreme court that is six to three with
a conservative super majority
i mean it's hard to say actually there
are some courts that will take those
into account um different configurations
of the court of course and then there
are some uh configurations of the court
that won't um to my knowledge it doesn't
seem as though the scotus that now
exists is um antagonistic to these
particular briefs um but you know
with the political persuasion on the
court right now it's hard to see if
those arguments will actually uh play a
large role when they make their final
decision i see i see
what what is the timeline here for us to
get some kind of decision from the
supreme court do you think
so the court will probably hear this um
this case uh in the next term um and
then you expect an uh an opinion maybe
six to eight weeks afterwards okay got
it so i'm thinking about
the summer late summer late summer just
in time for the next class of kids to
apply to colleges latoya baldwin clark
really appreciate your joining us to
give us your take on this ucla school of
law assistant professor
thank you so much